[Aplausos]
[Música]
con ramón gálvez soy licenciado en
gestión y alta dirección convención en
gestión social de la universidad
católica
actualmente soy director general de la
asociación sonríe corazón
de hecho preguntarán lo que hace un
simbolito acá que hacen este forum y acá
qué está haciendo acá cuando yo tengo 24
años y desde mi corta edad hice una
organización cree una organización en
base a una experiencia es por eso que a
partir de ello vamos a comentarles
principalmente bien estas imágenes
que se observan con estas imágenes
en este caso podemos apreciar este es
una imagen que publicó el unicef en un
diario de él es de españa en donde
justamente se identifica lo que es la
pobre la pobreza infantil
podemos observar una niña muy pequeña
cargando a su hermanito y justamente lo
está tratando de llevar un plato de
comida a su casa
acabado podemos observar otra imagen de
hecho esta imagen es muy impactante
porque sucede en la vida real de nuestra
cuando vamos en el carro cuando vamos en
el ómnibus cuando vamos pasamos por la
calle y que vemos una serie de
familiares de señoras de jóvenes de
niños que venden caramelos en las calles
para tener un plato de comida en su casa
esta señora es la señora doña y sidra
una señora de ciudad de méxico que
justamente en este caso no incidirá
salía a las 3 de la mañana se levantaba
muy temprano para preparar sus postres y
salir a venderlos con su silla de ruedas
y justamente la señora de hoy sidra
comentaba que tiene 87 años salía cada
vez los días para vender estos postres y
sacar su tiendita
esta imagen creo que la vemos en las
noticias donde acabo más en san juan de
lurigancho en san martín de porres envía
maría del triunfo villa el salvador
justamente que observamos
donde personas se levantan muy temprano
para con un balde
bajan y tener un balde de agua
la verdad es muy frustrante ver estas
imágenes
esta es otra imagen que podemos observar
donde niños tienen un solo plato de
comida
y la verdad a mí me llena de frustración
me llena de un poco de ansiedad para
saber qué es lo que yo puedo hacer por
ellos
un solo plato de comida ni siquiera
lleno todo el plato para que estos niños
puedan comer todos los días
y en esta imagen que podemos observar
donde niños están estudiando básicamente
en la basura
donde recolectan cuadernos diarios para
ponerse a estudiar si en ciertos
momentos
y esto lo podemos ver a cabo más acá en
el animal necesario ir a las zonas
rurales para poder observar esta
situación que sucede en el país ahora
creo que ustedes pueden observar estas
frases que justamente se escuchan muy a
menudo donde dicen el gobierno debería
hacer algo en otro país tendré más
oportunidades mejor me voy al país mi
país está así porque la verdad es que no
quiere hacer nada
o el gobierno no hace nada cada vez el
perú está peor o incluso dicen no la
educación es mala hay mucha inseguridad
en mi país la verdad que prefiero irme a
estudiar a europa irme a estudiar a eeuu
donde la educación es mucho mejor
y así podemos escuchar estas frases
diariamente en las redes sociales en
instagram en facebook donde la gente
justamente comenta estas frases
y ahora
que yo les quiero contar con esto
bueno todo empezó en el año 2018 donde
justamente me fui
de intercambio al té de monterrey en la
ciudad de guadalajara entonces en un
pequeño trayecto en una de esas
vacaciones que hubo dentro de la
universidad tuve una semana de
vacaciones en donde justamente en este
caso lo que sucedió es que yo aprovecha
no dije voy a ahorrar me voy de
vacaciones una una aventura no diga a mí
me encanta la aventura entonces dije
bueno me voy me voy
me voy a ciudad de méxico entonces yo
dije no voy a tomar varias fotos con mi
celular chanchito con lo que tengo pero
me tomé fotos me fui al bosque de
chapultepec al castillo de chapultepec
y bueno estuve allí hasta más o menos
siete de la noche aproximadamente
en ese momento más o menos ya las 7 de
la noche me dirijo al paredero
aparecerá el camión como liz anahí en
mexico y estuve esperando como más o
menos 30 minutos a 40 a 45 minutos más o
menos y en ese momento se me acerca a
una señora se me acercó una señora con
su bolsita caramelos
la señora se llama señora carmela donde
me dijo joven tengo sólo 10 caramelos
por favor me podría colaborar
bueno eliges estar ya el señor no se
preocupe cuánto es 30 pesos genial señor
acá tengo justito tenía 30 pesos le
pagué
y la señora comenzó a llorar
y yo dije qué pasó qué sucedió dije y
dije algo malo
me tocó el corazón me comenzó a
lagrimear
y me sacó de su bolsillo
una paleta un chupetín
y la señora mi hijo está mejor en el
regalo porque le estoy regalando y sabe
porque me he puesto así porque es la
primera vez que termino mi bolsa de
caramelos
y yo me quedé en shock dije porque qué
pasa
yo vendo los caramelos me levanto a las
5 de la mañana para listar el desayuno
de mis hijos tengo 5 hijos soy madre
soltera no tengo el apoyo de nadie
mi familia me abandonó
y justamente mi hijo el mayor va a
terminar la secundaria
entonces
dije señor bate nueva secundaria que
quiere hacer su hijo
me dijo la verdad no tengo la menor idea
yo solamente quiero que mi hijo salga
adelante y se cumpla su sueño
cumpla sus sueños tal vez ser abogado
ser artista ser ingeniero no lo sé pero
yo quiero que mi hijo salga adelante
ahí entendí perfectamente que la
situación en nuestro país es muy similar
dije guau
porque nosotros nos quejamos tanto
y decimos que la situación está así y no
hacemos algo por nuestro país o no
hacemos algo por nuestra comunidad
entonces después de eso yo dije me voy a
poner a averiguar
y encontrar algunas frases algunas datos
que justamente que más de tres millones
de las personas adultas en las zonas
rurales no han terminado la secundaria
básica
es una gran proporción de el perú
otra otra estadística que justamente es
que el 24% del nivel de estudiantes de
secundaria la comparación de las zonas
rurales lastimosamente no pueden
terminar la educación no presentan
retraso escolar
otro de ellos es que 13 por ciento de
los estudiantes
normalmente de 4º grado de las zonas
rurales
presentan déficit en retraso escolar en
comprensión lectora y matemáticas
y ocho de cada diez estudiantes terminan
embarazadas y no logran terminar la
secundaria
a partir de ello nació una realización
con una idea
de cinco chicos cinco jóvenes que
estuvieron dispuestos a hacer de una
educación
de calidad
nosotros salimos adelante
y dijimos nos vamos con todo tenemos que
hacer algo por nuestro país algo por
nuestro perú entonces comenzamos a
lograr a hablar con los estudiantes con
los colegios a hacer algunos talleres
venir de aquí para allá y poco a poco
nació esta idea de que nosotros debemos
contribuir con la educación
así que comenzamos a ir a varios lugares
h&p apagando a polo nuevo acá en lima
también a la zona de coma esa
independencia
y poco a poco muchos jóvenes comenzaron
a integrar la organización
comenzamos a hacer más talleres más
actividades de responsabilidad social
por ejemplo pudimos también ir a hacer
algunas compras y terapia física y
rehabilitación para un seva donde
justamente este colegio necesitaba
algunos aparatos de ello y lo mandamos a
san martín a la selva rioja
también bueno a partir de ahí yo también
hicimos algunas autoras actividades como
chocolatada como nos invitaron algunas
conferencias en la universidad de
callado de san marcos en la católica
y a partir de ellos nosotros
identificamos que hay que hacer mejor
proyectos que generen un impacto social
que genera un impacto en los estudiantes
es por eso que justamente nosotros
tenemos dos proyectos el primer proyecto
esté enfocado a lo que es desarrollo de
habilidades blandas lo pusimos el nombre
de formando líderes de mañana y el
segundo proyecto que justamente nació en
el año 2019
se llama soñar los libros y este año
hemos escogido una edición muy especial
llamado edición bicentenario
en donde justamente el proyecto soñando
libros tiene la finalidad de contribuir
y desarrollar nuevos hábitos de lectura
en los estudiantes generar los tres
tipos de comprensión lectora
literaria
crítica inferencial ahora eso no quiere
decir que nosotros vamos y hablamos con
los estudiantes y los enseñamos a leer
no
esto genera a que los estudiantes a
través de una obra literaria
puedan entender la realidad social de su
país
que sean críticos de la situación en
donde se enfrentan
últimamente se ha visto mucha situación
en la cual en las redes sociales
comentarios negativos
comentarios sobre discriminación sobre
el racismo sobre injusticias sociales y
es por eso que este año hemos decidido
escoger obras literarias enfocados
a que muestren esta realidad de nuestro
país y los estudiantes
reflexionen sobre esta situación sean
críticos de su país
es por eso que nosotros escogimos estas
obras y lo llevamos actualmente con 5
instituciones educativas pero no solo
lima de hecho aprovechamos la
virtualidad para poder desarrollar este
proyecto y nos fuimos a desarrollar
actividades con cajamarca con huánuco
con pueblo nuevo con chepén
se re pasco y acá en comas
y hay otras instituciones de algunos
chicos que también han querido
integrarse a este proyecto y nosotros
bienvenido sea
y todo esto en verdad a mí me
enorgullece ver la sonrisa de estos
niños que trabajan con nosotros y nos
agradecen muchísimo cuando nos vamos de
más siempre quieren desean que nos
quedemos no dicen muchísimas gracias
en verdad profesor maestro
en lugar de haber niños que estén en las
calles vendiendo caramelos
en lugar de ver niños que están en la
basura haciendo sus tareas porque el no
ver estas sonrisas de estos niños
porque al no ver al niño que en verdad
disfruten de esta educación en su país
del deporte de la cultura del arte de la
ciencia
con una finalidad que estos chicos
generen una vocación que tengan una
vocación en ellos
es importante ver la sonrisa la sonrisa
de estos pequeños
estos niños niñas y adolescentes
y todo esto se debe a un gran equipo
humano unos equipos que lo integran la
asociación sonríe el corazón y ya no
solamente lo integran 5 chicos ya no son
cinco personas como iniciamos hace hace
cuatro años aproximadamente
ya no son cuatro estudiantes cuatro
jóvenes cinco jóvenes que están teniendo
ese sueño sino son 108 jóvenes que
conforman dentro de la asociación que
justamente tienen una finalidad de hacer
una educación de calidad por su país
ahora así que justamente me estás
escuchando
te quiero hacer algunas preguntas y tú
qué piensas hacer ahora por tu país en
verdad
ponte a reflexionar te quedarás con los
brazos cruzados
dejarás que la situación en nuestro país
y ver muchas críticas en las redes
sociales que en la verdad a veces ya me
harta mucho ver tanta gente que critica
a su país y en lugar de criticar porque
no hacer algo por nuestro país
seguiremos que jan uno de nuestro país
es por eso que yo les digo
no nos preguntemos
qué es lo que nuestro país puede hacer
por nosotros sino más bien lo contrario
qué es lo que ustedes como verdaderos
agentes de cambio pueden hacer por su
país
porque su país lo vio nacer
ustedes nacieron acá son peruanos
y la verdad
y yo quiero hacer todo por el país amo
mi perú amo a mi patria
y no solamente es amar la gastronomía no
solamente es amar los lugares turísticos
sino de una u otra forma
amar también a mi país por más problemas
que existan yo deseo contribuir hacia mi
país salir adelante
y así a ti te invito
aquí ahora
reflexiones y te pongas a pensar
qué es lo que tú vas a hacer
con alguna acción mínima
que tú estés dispuesto a hacer en el
carro a cabo más saliendo cinco minutos
que es lo que tú puedes hacer por tu
país que lo que tú puedes hacer por tu
comunidad
y esas acciones
hasta pueden cambiar la vida de una
persona
no se imaginan que la señora carmela
cuando yo le termine de comprar esos 10
caramelos como se quedó llorando
yo me quedé en shock la verdad porque
fue una historia que justamente
me tocó y recordé que en mi país yo en
los carros veo mucha gente que sale a
vender sus caramelitos
a cantar a bailar niños también con sus
mamás con sus papás
y es porque quieren un futuro mejor
angela y tienen un señor mejor y
nosotros como jóvenes como adultos
que ya pasamos una etapa y poder
contribuir por tu país
y podemos ser un agente de cambio
cada uno de nosotros podemos ser un
agente de cambio porque todos podemos
ser agentes de cambio muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]